members can i bring this meeting please
sorry
good evening and welcome to this meeting
on the development committee i will now
read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entry doors to the hall
contact continue straight on go through
the two sets of double doors on the
right hand side to the car park which is
the assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by the
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobile mobile phones
or turn them to silence or leave them
like me left at home
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
where where possible please help by
passing the microphones to each other
and use the hand gel and antibacterial
wipes on the tables if you do touch the
microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
against the recommendations and then for
those wishing to abstain from voting
item
agendas one and two apologies for
absences and absence and substitutes
we've received apologies from councillor
david merrick and councillor david
sperring will be substituting for david
merrick is there any others please
i don't think so i think we've got all
the members here
well we've got we can't stop the meeting
because someone's running late thank you
we have we
this meeting has to start at 7 30. so
we um he will when he comes there is a
seat for him
thank you
non-members attending
there's
stuart's counselor stuart wilson
councillor
woodson and councillor cheryl rowe
you're at the back there thank you have
i missed anybody
no thank you
minutes of the meeting held on the 29th
of july
are these
okay can i have a vote so please
any alterations
nope thank you
to receive declarations of interest
members if you do think you want a
declaration please do so through the
meeting
members before we start today's business
i would like to move a motion without
notice to change the order of business
in order to take item nine
twenty slash zero one zero four four
zero four one slash rem land north of
london road
item eight so nine is going to come
before eight have i got
a seconder please
thank you very much
can i have
everyone in favor for changing this
please
that is unanimous thank you
right item agenda item six
is
twenties
thank you twenty zero zero three three
two full land opposite 92 to 102
windermere
to consider an application for proposed
erection of
17
number dwellings 11
number houses and one building
containing six flats with associated
access parking and private amenity space
and it is
mr shranks could you please do it
have you got
a fine
its application is to a parcel of land
on the southern side of windermere
avenue and although members will recall
this went to committee back in december
i've got to put this up higher it seems
forgive me everyone
there you go um it's worth getting the
context just briefly because i'm going
to show the adjoining development
members will recall that this area of
land wider area and it goes off the page
was released from
the green belt in your allocations plan
so it was green belt
and became residentially allocated and
then since that time
there's been a
planning permission granted on the
larger part of the site which most
members would i think know is being
built by david wilson homes
this site tonight
doesn't include
that
that piece of land that's subject to the
outline i think when this went to
committee before in december
there was some confusion about what
barrets had said they would do as
opposed to the proposal before you so
just to tidy that up
you'll see that we're talking about this
section of land here and this land here
is yet to come before us these are
excluded from the outline permission
over the greater site given to to
barrett so this isn't part of the
barrett site think of it as a
stand-alone site if we can just look at
the malians lane development please plan
two
just to build on what i've just said our
site is up here
this is the development that's currently
under construction that i was explaining
and the obligations of this if you like
nothing to do with this site so whatever
the developers said they would do here
this developer isn't necessarily bound
by that i felt i do
need to make that clear
if we can look at the site layout plan 3
for this application please members
remember that a scheme that's fairly
similar to this was brought
before members on the i think it's the
10th of december last year
and members had a number of concerns
which are set out in the report
that concerning density and the heights
of the buildings etc and the applicants
have gone away and they've adjusted the
scheme
that you see before you
the density obviously remains the same
still the number same number of 17
dwellings six flats 11 houses
but if you think that your policy says
that all schemes should reach at least
30 dwellings per hectare this scheme
equates at 37 per hectare so officers as
previously
support the density
and what the applicants have done have
largely kept the
sort of spirit of the design of the
buildings but they've looked at the
individual
criticisms that members had
and they've made made adjustments to it
so
we will see that the garden areas on
this have all now been made up to 100
square meters they were
some of these on the lower part here
were over 90 but didn't meet 100
they've taken out one house type and
adjusted the layout such that the
gardener areas now all comply with your
requirements
um we have a plan
3a if we could jump to that please
if members with a keen eye can see
there's a dotted line here
and that is the scheme that you saw in
december the dotted line and what the
applicant has been able to do is to
change the heights they've
dropped uh house type a by a 0.4 of a
meter
they've dropped house type b by 0.5 of a
meter
to a height of 9.4 house type a is 8.9
meters in height and the apartment
building has been lowered by 0.8 of a
meter to
9.7 meters
if we can go back to house type plan
four please house type two
members raise the concern about the
inability to sort of open a car door in
the carport feature and what the
applicant has done although keeping
faith with the main design
they've taken the wall out so that
they've got the support with the
two squares that you can see there this
is a planned view so they've cut the
roof and lifted it off and you're
looking down above
but they've been able to attend to that
criticism uh by doing that i think have
we got a um
no we haven't i thought we've got the
design
yeah plan four is this plan yes sorry my
mistake
here look you can see the opening where
the carport is
i thought this was on another plan but
this is all on one plan
there's the opening where they've taken
the walling away and here we see it on
plan where they've taken that out
if we go to the parking lot plan five
please
this scheme now fully complies with your
car parking standards there was some
concern that some visitor parking was to
be provided in these
uh plots to the to the south and i think
that was felt that the owners of the
houses would sort of take ownership of
those not that it would be theirs but
it'd be sort of uncomfortable for
visitors visiting another plot to park
uh on almost what was somebody else's
property so whilst they were achieving
the garden areas and they were changing
the houses slightly they took those out
and this is compliant with your
standards there's two visitor spaces for
the flatted scheme and the three
required visitor spaces are up here i
know that's away from some of these here
but the highway authority does entertain
curbside parking so as a scheme this is
compliant with your standards each
dwelling has got two spaces except the
one bed flats which has got one space
and you're required to have four point
something visitor spaces so they of
course can't have a point something of a
space so they've made it fine
if we see the boundary treatment plan
plan six please the applicants have put
in hedging and landscaping
to give a good setting to the building
here and the site front is you'll see
that the street areas are enclosed by
walling and then subdivided by fences in
a typical
style
if we can see the
plan seven the aerial image please this
is a computer generated image i don't
think we had this last time
but i don't know if you can zoom in on
that where you can please claire what
they've done is to try and show you the
development of the back that's the
barrett scheme which is already approved
and is being built but they're trying to
show you how their proposed scheme would
look in context and you'll see this is
windermere avenue here
these are the buildings that were from
windermere avenue and there's the access
road that we saw
that we were speaking to a moment ago
and you'll see the walling around the
perimeters of the garden areas that back
onto that
members uh were concerned about secure
by design in
working on these drawings because these
were initially presented to you in
december the applicants have gone back
to essex police and you'll see in your
report there's a letter of comfort set
out at paragraph 4.30 on page 661
that they've had constructive
consultation on these changes and the
revised design before you would achieve
an appropriate level of certification
under secure by design i get the
impression there's various categories so
whilst they can't yet be clear as to
which one they would hit they're saying
to you it would get one of those in in
if built
you'll see that the essex county council
sustainable drainage team have no
objection subject to conditions
on the drainage issues proposed the fact
that the county subs team recommend
conditions doesn't mean that there's a
problem with the scheme it's more for
enforceability that the
matters laid down by the applicant as
what they should do and will do
if they're a subject of a condition they
can then be enforced so it's a matter of
housekeeping really
then lastly there was the issue about
the use of windermere avenue legally
members will recall being concerned that
it was it's an unmade road
um but there is public right over it
you'll see in the report that both the
applicant and essex county council
confirm that it's not maintainable at
public expense but there is a right to
pass over this street by vehicles and on
foot
the council's allocation plan makes
clear that there's no reference
that came out i think in representations
made that there should be all the
developments served through the barrett
site the allocations plan that you have
approved actually says that there should
be at least two
entry exit points into the development
of the allocation
the barrett scheme has an access on to
uh
holdbridge road lower road and
malians lane
this scheme which is much smaller
accesses into windermere avenue so the
development of what you allocated from
the greenbelt as a whole
if this was approved would have three
access points across it as an entirety
when you've asked for it to have at
least two so this would
meet that requirement
the recommendation you'll see chairman
um is approval now
i said earlier at the start to make a
clear distinction
that this is not part of the barrett
site
but because this is an allocated site
this isn't like infilling you get in in
other streets and areas
the developers for this must also
contribute to infrastructure just like
barrett
so you will see that there is a number
of points recommended in the legal
agreement that might
be the same as barrett for instance
education contributions things like this
now that is because you've taken the
land out of the green belt and then
these schemes have to deliver on that
infrastructure now there are some things
that barrett has done
because they're engineering projects
which these people can't can't do it's
already been built so you can't
add to it
but you'll see that officers have gone
through the report but where there are
outstanding matters or there are monies
accrued just based on the number of uh
dwellings then we're asking that there
be a legal agreement should you approve
it
to those points yeah
and that would be the consistent
approach to all the developers of the
land barely mind there is still a vacant
parcel uh to the west of this site
that has yet to come come before you and
lastly in addition to the legal
agreement chairman the conditions that
are set up at paragraph 1.1 onwards
thank you
we have the agent uh for this uh it's
james firth
uh you'll have five minutes to speak and
we'll give you a minute
when it's up we've got a minute left
thank you
okay
okay thank you um
good evening my name is james firth
director at stratton parker speaking on
behalf of martin holmes the applicant
as you've heard the planning application
before you has been running a long time
since submission
last year it was first reported to
committee in december and deferred for a
number of reasons
i'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to address those concerns
and my clients and ourselves have been
working hard with your officers as as
you've heard to address the different
issues that have been raised
there's been further informational
clarification provided on a number of
points and there's been changes made to
the scheme
as you've heard the site of course forms
part of an allocated site scr-6 and
therefore presents next opportunity to
contribute to housing needs of both
market and affordable housing
we've undertaken pacific further
engagement with essex police including a
meeting with angie andy pearson the
secured by design officer
and the scheme will incorporate secured
by design measures that were recommended
in that through those discussions in
particular door entry systems
appropriate boundary treatments lighting
and surveillance within the scheme
the scheme therefore meets policy
requirements for secured by design
there's been a design review as you've
heard in a reduction in building heights
across the scheme
the revised information package included
a design update document from the
architect's dap
and there's been a reduction in ridge
heights taking into account the
neighbouring scheme as you've heard
houses reduced by 0.4 0.5 and apartments
by 0.8
the apartment's also been reduced down
to
the eaves to 2.5 story and personally i
feel this has resulted in a real
improvement to the appearance of the
scheme from the from the street scene
and the elevations so
thank you again for that input
the poses otherwise meet design
requirements to avoid any overbearing
and distances and they include shared
amenities spaces you heard
parking base sizes have all been
reviewed and changes have been made to
ensure the parking works in relation to
walls which was the concern previously
through the
the adjustment of the carports within
the scheme
access is onto the public highway which
has been confirmed by its county council
and there's a a letter confirmation
provided from them
uh 1.1 f in your recommendation also
covers the resurfacing and pavement
construction works on windermere avenue
as one of the number of uh section 106
items that
that's just been covered
there is no objection from ecc highways
the design review also ensures there is
a hundred square meter garden area three
three changes to the layout for all of
the properties
and the scheme layout is therefore
policy compliant and does not present uh
represent over development and meeting
the policy requirements
a drainage strategy
has been submitted
it is
this foundation is considered there will
be a low risk of flooding from
groundwater across the site and a very
low risk of flooding from other sources
such as surface water
due to the type of soil this is an
attenuation solution rather than
infiltration using permeable paving and
attenuation and the existing runoff rate
of 0.9 liters per second
and and the scheme has been designed to
a discharge rate of 0.9 liters per
second therefore not increasing
the runoff or flood risk from the
current situation there's further
conditions on that as you've heard
ecc suds confirm this is appropriate and
there's no objection
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with regard to any other matters of
detail
regarding conditions or 106 we will of
course continue to work with your
officers we very much hope you are able
to support the scheme tonight
thank you
thank you very much
i will now invite
the world members uh
who are here and it is um
i think we've only got a
councillor stuart wilson i think we've
got any
other members so
just non-members so
thank you madam chair um
i note from the previous report there
have definitely been some improvements
to the scheme but there are three areas
that i would like members to take
consideration of the first is parking
while it's true that the scheme now
meets the minimum standards for parking
in the vicinity of the of the area in
windermere avenue there's no
place or no space is available for
additional parking so i'll ask members
to be mindful of that the second point
is to do with height and as the agent
has just said the ridge height has been
reduced and that's good because this is
still the highest point in holbridge but
i would ask members to satisfy yourself
that there are no overlooking issues
either to existing properties in
windermere avenue or to the new
properties that are to be built by
barrett david wilson homes
the third point
relates to the
access via the private road and i
contend that it's the report is actually
contradictory in places members may wish
to look at paragraphs
3.15
3.116
and 3.117
and in
those paragraphs
in paragraph 3116 says essex highways
have provided the following response by
email it would appear that windermere
revenue in the vicinity of the proposal
is not adopted highway the section of
road is a private road
private roads are not adopted by the
local authority and therefore
maintenance and upkeep are
responsibility of the landowner
and then paragraph 3.117
says that given that the access from the
private
from a private road the access rights
are a private matter and have no
implications on the highway authority
recommendation
if members were minded to approve this i
would ask that we consider a previous
precedent that was set which was in
lower road 66 lower road the case number
was one nine
stroke zero zero sorry zero one one
eight five stroke ful
and this had a very similar um scenario
i think members will remember that this
was the old bicycle shop on lower road
and that access was via a private road
and at the time the landowner didn't
give permission for the developers to
have access to the gardens as well the
parking bays at the rear so
i would ask members if you are minded to
approve it to put in a similar condition
which is to make sure that that you are
satisfied that the there is legal um
access onto the site thank you madam
chair
sorry is there any other non-members
want to speak
oh thank you
we'll come back right
to the members the committee councillor
sparring
sorry sonia
thank you chairman in in light of what
uh council wilson's just said can i ask
for some guidance from our legal
department i assuming that they have
looked into this aspect and are
comfortable with what has been proposed
and what has been agreed
can i just clarify the question sorry um
in terms of if you're talking about this
being um and mr strength will correct me
if i'm wrong but in terms of um
rights of way and that sort of thing we
don't consider that to be a material
consideration in terms of planning
um
and those sort of disputes i would say
are
separate um separate between the private
landowners
if that says yeah i mean
subject to us approving this we're not
going to run into a problem that
suddenly they can't get access to this
site is is i assume this has all been
looked into and i mean i'm aware of
another issue that we have and and this
has happened and
there is a very big site that has to go
down a similar sort of scenario
um and it it works as long as as you you
you as planning say that you know there
isn't going to be an issue with regard
to
either construction and or subject sub
suitable residents uh being able to make
access
to this development
that i think is what we need to know is
no good us saying yes we can and then
there'd be a legal issue that
they can't make access to it
chairman if i may
what you have before you is the
applicants have explored this matter in
their preparation and diligence in
bringing the application to you
and as a result of members comments back
in december they've
tried to go further and assured
themselves you also have a letter from
the county council highway authority
who say
the
section of streets that the
site fronts the unmade section
whilst not maintained at public expense
it enjoys rights of passage by virtue of
foot or vehicle
so
i think
the highways authority who we would rely
on though it's not something they
administer as such
they're confirming what your applicants
are telling you that they've in the
belief they have
have right of access now
without trying to muddy the waters it
wouldn't probably the first time that
sometimes when things progress they hit
problems that's the nature of the
development industry but the developers
do everything in their power to make
sure if they're interested in a site
they're not buying a pup that they can't
get no access to
so
the applicants were already ahead of you
before the application came to you in
december and they've gone further and
the highway authority to confirm it i'd
like to think members can be reassured
that this site enjoys access i think
there may be a common perception amongst
the public that because it's not an
adopted street
that then only certain people can can
pass over it but that's not the case
they're entitled to to pass over it and
i think there's something in the
application particulars forgive me i
didn't author this report
but that says that the developers are
going to improve the surface anyway
so
i think you can be assured that there is
public right of passage over this street
that fronts the site
thank you
counselors
thank you chair
um notwithstanding the comments that uh
mr strange has just made one of the
things that i think is uh needs
clarification we have got confirmation
from essex county council that there is
right of way on the frontage of this
site
but the right of way does include then
the rest of the road
and i'm just wondering if there is
any issue there i'm not yet convinced i
must be honest
because i i like uh councillor spurring
know of another site
where a developer developed a very big
site
and because of a strip of land there's
public right of way over it but wasn't
owned by the actual
applicant at the time
that they then did not were denied
access to that site and eventually that
that
large contractor went bust
as a result of that so i'm not convinced
by what i've actually heard at the
moment
uh from the point of view of access
being free
on another couple of comments i don't
think the
picture that we're actually looking at
the moment actually does the applicant
any favors
what we're actually seeing behind in the
david wilson's
project is well-spaced houses
of these decent sizes i think the scale
of ma and mass of what we're actually
seeing in the applicant's
proposals that he's bringing tonight are
a questionable
i think scale and mass is certainly
something that
i would be uh querying about this
where we looked at the uh the reduction
in height
of especially the flatted complex i'm
not sure that's come down enough
i know it's come down but when you
actually look at it it's the central
piece of the roof
that has actually come down and the rest
of it has pretty much stayed where it
was in the first place
so i'm not
minded at the moment
to
agree that this has actually gone far
enough
in its actual uh revisions
and uh
that's pretty much all i have to say
thank you thank you can you pass the uh
microphone to councillor stanley and
went after that counselor stan lee can
you pass that to councillor lorman
please so
yes thank you
thank you chairman um
with effect to the
what has just been said
is the
block that we see in front of us
with a large flat roof to the rear
and much concerns about that in
the size of that flat roof if it is such
um perhaps the officer could let us know
and also
is there any restrictions
for
the occupants
not to park
in the parking bays or the
tunnel or whatever you like to call it
at the side of the property
is there a restriction for them not to
park in the road and that they must park
their cars in those areas that the
parking bays are suitable for and the
last thing is
in relation to this
it's
quite overcrowded
as opposed to the
properties surrounding this this site
i do feel that it's over developed
and
that it doesn't marry up to the existing
surroundings
in any shape or form
and perhaps
a second look at it
would be helpful
you say there are three
uh
ways out
from that site but i can only see one
out there at the moment
excuse me uh
my
office of strengths
clarify what you've just said
forgive me chairman i've pulled myself
onto the punch i was trying to avoid
um
this scheme as you rightly see has one
entrance point on to windermere avenue
when you considered it back in december
there were objections raised by
residents saying that
the development of the site you
allocated as a whole including barrett's
davy wilson homes
should be
accessed from the south they felt that
your plan said it must be accessed from
the south yeah
now your plan does not say that your
plan says that the site as a whole
including david wilson homes should have
at least
two access points
and the point i was trying to make is
that
it isn't required of the plan we work to
that the council produced with public
consultation viewed by an inspector
it isn't a requirement that this site is
fed from the back from the south
it's just a required requirement of the
allocation as a whole all of the land
you release from the green belt to have
at least two access points what this
scheme does is give you a third in the
service of the site as a whole albeit
only these 17 units
yeah
i think i was trying to correct the
concern that was raised by members of
the public in the representations
possibly messed that up and confused
members but
so what you see on the screen is one
access point for just this group
but but what you released as a whole was
required to have at least two access
points this third access point satisfies
your policy because it creates a third
access albeit just for these 1 17.
i've hopefully made that clear i hope
gem thank you
can i come back to you please as long as
we
this is a really heavy agenda councillor
stanley so we need to get move things on
so unless you're you're not going to
repeat yourself
i'm not going to repeat that i'll just
say asking you or not i mean
okay no no i'm not saying you're going
along with it then i mean if we haven't
got the time to do it so we
i just didn't want things repeated
bye bye so please carry on then we're
going to council lawman thank you
um
we did mention that the
barrett holmes was a separate
uh
development from the off
so why are we including the barrett
homes development in this site in the
first place
i'm getting confused here because you're
dealing with two sites and yet
we're talking about one site not two
sites council stanley we are actually
only talking about this site and it was
just no no no it was just noted that um
site there is two extra
exits so
um this is no that's what i said i know
that but is it to do with this side no
it's the point
if you read your papers on item six it
isn't this we are not discussing barrett
huns
and if you had read your papers you
would have known that well i did read
that well obviously you didn't read them
properly um counselor
did i have any other questions how many
more you got please well i had another
two which i've okay you've only got five
minutes
everyone on this table has only got five
minutes to speak yeah right okay and
you've only got about a minute and a
half well i'm just waiting for the
answer
i've just given it to you
oh you you're going to give me the
answer about parking are you no no i've
just given you the one for bar at home
so i asked the one about the parking
well i was already asked that when i
started
so if nobody's listening
well we are but we just wanted to make
sure you've got all your questions in
one go and then they can be answered
i was going to ask if the officer would
like to answer all the questions in one
go
okay would you like to carry on ask what
um
um if you didn't mind chairman i'd
rather just while they're hot i'd just
rather kind of deal with those
you could you can uh as i say take a
horse to water but you can't make it
drink all we can do as planners is make
the car parking spaces available in the
layout
what we can't insist upon there's no
power to make people stop parking on the
street unless you start putting
regulations down traffic you know um w
lines things like that so
we make the provision available in the
decisions and it's hoped that people
will use their parking space but that
doesn't stop them parking on the street
if it's convenient to do so or pizza
deliveries things like that there was a
point raised about flat roof and i think
it was to do with the flattened building
here
i'm i'm at a loss i can't see flat roof
other than architectural detailing
you'll see see this like uh ridge line
and two hips down that's a fully ridged
ridge roof i i can't see a large expanse
of flat roof but the sort of the dormer
features and the castellation in the
uh articulation of the building they
might have flat roofed elements but
they're minor in relation to the to the
wider scheme i think
um
that's the scope of the questions that i
was hoping to address them thank you
councillor
please
you've got one in front of your council
alone
somebody said you've got one in front of
him
yes thank you is it on yeah yeah i'm
wearing this so yeah bear with me i
can't
anyway so um
some of the questions are relevant to
what i was going to ask so i'm not going
to sort of double date this thing but
it became obvious to me that we've
talked first of all about the
accessibility of windermere road and
you're all going on about over this part
that part but really surely if there's a
point of legal point of accessibility
that's for the
the applicant to prove to us that it's
not for us to guess or or just take for
granted surely we should have something
if we're going to look at this we should
have something before us to say this is
what we've done this is what we've
achieved this is the legal status it's
not for us to sit here and and play snap
you know what i mean anyway that's my
point on that one but what i wanted to
say was and it comes back to this
actually
accessibility issue there's only one to
this site
now you've asked for two on the other
big site we won't go into that but one
assumes that's for health and safety and
everything else in and out and
everything else but if there was an
incident because if it's on an adoptive
road no lawful parking restrictions
could be put in
so
i'm not that's my understanding so if
someone was to park a big lorry at that
entrance the whole site is blocked
similarly if there was an incident
any incident even digging the road up to
block that entrance how do all the
people get in and out especially in an
emergency situation i note on the far
right side of it it goes on to land or
whatever i don't know i'm not familiar
with the area so does it go into where a
road can be taken out that side on the
right-hand side of that drawing you had
the plan
the site plan
you got it
was it number three or four that see
you come in for the main one this end's
all blocked off with trees because it
goes on to the wilson state but what is
on that side can they not take it
another opening there to take it back to
windermere road
anyway there's some questions i just
thought and that's all i want to say
really thank
very quickly chairman um if you go back
to the location plan
um
windermere avenue here which we're
looking at this plot there's an
alternative access out if this were ever
blocked
leads you into grasmere um it's a
traditional gridiron so
it wouldn't be inevitable that sometimes
places get blocked because say a house
fire or something like that lord forbid
but this isn't landlocked by access most
traffic will probably go that way but
some may choose to go out through that
one
if we could look at the state layout for
this one please i think as i say i've
tried to fix problems from the last time
you saw it i think i've created now it's
all right
this is a single access point and all it
does is serve this small group
but when you saw it before there was
concerns about the sort of legacies from
the barrack development and that's what
i was hoping to fix for members line
that there is no permeability from this
into the barrett site
it's a small culture
potentially 17 unless you slew the ones
on the front but i take the point but
that that's no different to schemes we
see a lot in this committee
small cul-de-sac developments in
the highway authority doesn't object to
this layout and its impact on the strut
on the strategic network
thank you councillor williams yeah thank
you thank you very much chairman um it
seems that we're moving the goalposts
here um
at the last meeting that this was
brought up out in the last committee
meeting we
raised some concerns that we had
they have been addressed as far as we
can see
we're now bringing up further concerns
and to me it just doesn't seem right
there are many many cul-de-sacs in our
area and are we going to have them all
changed of course we're not i would like
to propose that we take this to a vote
now for approval thank you
every second
right members you've heard that you've
uh we've had emotions so for approval
can i have a vote on if you would it
just
it is
uh the planning permission be approved
subject to the completion of legal
agreement under section 106 of the act
for the heads of terms set out below
how can i have a vote on this please all
in favor
please keep your hands up until sonia's
counted
all against
any abstentions
this
remembers this has been approved eight
four eight four
four against one abstention thank you
oops right members we're going on to
item seven
michelin farm arterial road rally
and i believe it's katie who's going to
sorry
this application sorry claire can i go
onto the location plan please
this application site is situated at the
junction of the a127 to the south
and the a1245 that goes northwards there
the application site is that edged red
on the plan
on screen which is part of a wider site
under the same ownership
so the application site includes the
vertical access proposed onto the a125
to the northeast corner
and then runs parallel um to the railway
line along the site's northern boundary
the western boundary adjoins at a field
whilst the southern boundary i joined
anward lodge business park
here
which consists of a surface car park and
a cluster of fairly modest buildings
a single residential
dwelling also borders the site's
southern boundary in this location here
so the whole site
the red and the blue
save for a section of the southwest
corner here benefits from outline
planning permission for commercial
development
reserve matters has been approved in
this part of the site edge to blue
and development there has commenced
if you can take you to the site layout
please claire
so the proposal is for a single large
building for b2 general industrial and
v8 storage and distribution use
this building will be centrally
positioned so is shown here so it's
essentially
in the main a large rectangle
and there's hgv parking and access to
the building to both the north as hgv
parking here and to the south here and
then hgv access
to the building to the south and also to
the north
vehicular access would be here via this
access proposed onto the a1245
a smaller building in this location here
is proposed as a gatehouse building just
to control
the access road within the site
car parking will be proposed here just
to the
east of the site and in this location
just as you enter the site of the access
pedestrian and cycle access will be
provided and to the south to the sat
from the southern boundary so at this
point here
you can take it to the master plan
please claire
so this master plan is illustrative only
but shows the proposed development in
the context of the wider development of
the site
so the two commercial buildings here are
those subject to full consent and
they're under construction
i can take you to the uh warehouse
elevation please claire
so external facing materials would mimic
those used on the buildings in phase one
and already under construction
and the main roof shown in the section
here would be a series of shallow
pitches
and then on the elevation here you can
see that there's a parapet surrounding
so just shielding those shallow pitches
from view
two flat roofed sections so you can just
see these projecting here they're at a
lower height and they're fairly modest
would feature to both the northern and
southern elevations
some glazing so i don't know if it's
this section here
so some glazing would feature to the
building and they would the windows
would serve offices within the building
and then this north eastern corner is
the main
access to the building and this would
feature more glazing
can you teach plan six please claire
sorry
thank you so this is the landscaping
plan and so the soft landscaping will be
provided and includes native hedging so
it's going all around the perimeter down
here
and then significant tree planting
is also proposed
around the perimeter
and take you to the fencing plan please
claire
thank you
so the types of fencing proposed are
shown on the right hand side of the plan
here and the top one is 2.4 metre high
paladin fencing and that's proposed to
the whole of the site perimeter and then
some within the site and itself
cordoning off the this area of car
parking from the main warehouse building
this this hit and missed timber fencing
is only proposed um just to delineate
the refuse store
here
the other fencing proposed is this five
metre high acoustic fence
and if you can just zoom in to this
part of the southern boundary please
it's difficult to see but it's very
clear on a plan on the computer screen
so the acoustic fence would run along
this line here so all the way along the
rear garden boundary of this residential
property here and i would point out as
well in the course of the application a
number of these hgv parking bays here
have been removed from the layout would
be there would be an additional area of
soft landscaping provided
in this area immediately north and
adjoining
the garden to that residential dwelling
can you show the yes thank you
so several 3d images have been provided
by the applicant
and these are illustrative only but help
to give an impression of how the
proposal would appear
this image shows the northern elevation
with the proposed gatehouse building
in the foreground
i'll take you through a few photographs
that were taken fairly recently at the
site to help provide context to the
proposal
and the site location
so this first photograph is taken within
the application site looking east
towards the northeast corner of the site
and over here where the proposed vehicle
of access
would be
the building's under construction um
towards the right-hand side of the
screen can be seen and then this
towards the left is the railway
embankment
going to scroll down just a little bit
sorry
um
yeah this second image shows the
location of the proposed access onto the
a1245
um in the foreground so the axis would
come off here and then skirt
into the site and along the northern
boundary
this image shows the rear rear elevation
of anwood lodge so this is the
residential property bordering the site
i mean it shows in the context of the
the building already in
in under construction in phase one
and then the last image shows the rear
garden of this residential property uh
looking northwards um and the
application site then is beyond
that that boundary fence
the allocation plan please cloud yeah
so members this site is allocated for
employment use under policy nel1 of the
council's allocation plan as can be
shown on the extract on screen
but part of the site here is also is
allocated for a separate gypsy and
traveller accommodation use and that's
shown in the next extract so if you
could just go to that one so this is the
same site essentially but this is
showing the gypsy and traveller site
allocation
within the allocation plan document as
well so the site subject to two
different allocations in the adopted
development plan
so one of the key considerations in the
in the determination of this application
before members tonight is the conflict
with the adopted development plan in so
much as it would result in the loss of
the gypsy and traveller
site allocation
detailed consideration of this issue is
set out in the committee report but in
summary in the first instance
applications should be determined in
accordance with the adopted development
plan unless material considerations
indicate otherwise and would justify
departure from the plan
national planning policy required
sorry national planning policy
requires consideration as to whether a
reasonable prospect exists that an
application would come forward to
develop out this allocation
for the intended use of the gypsy and
traveller site
the applicant is clear that they do not
wish to develop the gypsy and traveler
site here
the only option would therefore be that
the council seek to acquire the site and
this would likely involve compulsory
purchase
as set out in the report this process
involves a number of stages and very
unlikely very significant costs to the
council
at this stage however compulsory
purchase of the gypsy and traveler
allocation cannot be ruled out
and the council leader and executive um
have indicated that compulsory purchase
should be explored here
officers have therefore concluded that a
reasonable prospect does exist
in all other respects the proposal is
however considered acceptable the
proposal would create significant jobs
which is a clear benefit of the scheme
although the building would be very
significant in scale it is considered
acceptable in this location
and harm to residential amenity of that
single property that borders the site
would we say be appropriately mitigated
following publication of the committee
report the applicant's
agent has submitted a letter which
raises a number of points they wish to
comment on
the comments include their view that an
alternative employment scheme could not
be achieved whilst retaining the gypsy
and traveler allocation at this site
their view that a reasonable prospect of
an application coming forward for a
gypsy and traveler
site here does does not exist is
reiterated
including reference to a compulsory
purchase process being unlikely to
succeed including as a result of
rochford council having to demonstrate
in the process that all necessary
resources to deliver the project are
likely to be available within a
reasonable time scale
also in the letter of importance to to
note to members this evening is the
applicant's proposal for an increased
financial contribution to 470 000 pounds
as opposed to the figure stated in the
office in the committee report
this will be towards alternative gypsy
and travel accommodation in the district
in recognition of the urgent and
pressing need for such
the recommendation members remains one
of refusal for the reason as stated in
the published report
thank you i'd like to ask mr tim
rainbird the agent to speak again you
have five minutes
and
we will let you know when there's one
minute there
good evening chair and members of the
development committee
i'm tim rainberg the agent speaking on
behalf of the applicant and owner of
michelin farm style uk rayleigh prop co
limited
i would like to start by thanking your
officers for the professional and
diligent way in which they've approached
this complex planning application
your officers are recommending refusal
on a single ground namely a departure
from your development plan i would like
to spend a few minutes explaining why i
strongly believe you should respectfully
consider granting planning permission
there is no doubt that this is a very
difficult application to judge but at
the heart of these proposals lies an
undeniable boost for the local economy
we've all endured a very challenging 18
months and you have an opportunity this
evening to facilitate the creation of up
to 800 new jobs
those jobs will deliver a post-pandemic
economic injection resulting in a 16
million pound direct investment and
approximately 1 million in business
rates
as you've heard the majority of the size
is already allocated for employment the
officers accept that significant
economic benefit would arise from the
proposal and that less economic benefit
should be afforded significant weight
despite this a number of factors have
tipped the planning balance against your
officers recommending approval those
factors are the belief that the land
allocated for gypsy and travel
accommodation is suitable and
deliverable
a possibility that an application will
come forward for gypsy and travel
accommodation and a belief that the
economic benefits will be delivered from
alternative or employment development
whilst retaining the gypsy and traveler
allocation
the site has clear suitability and
deliverability issues and fundamentally
it will not meet the needs of the gypsy
and traveller community the site is
surrounded by major roads the east coast
mainline and shadowed by high voltage
pylons the site also has no road access
and is believed to be heavily
contaminated
these factors indicate that the land
would be inappropriate for new homes for
either the travelling or settled
communities the site also has no gas
electricity or sewage connections
establishing these will require an
investment of all that 1.3 million
pounds
these issues have been raised by
planning inspectors when determining
appeals relating to gypsum travel
accommodation in the district
those inspectors have also heavily
criticized the reliance upon michelin
farm allocation given it does not offer
private traveler site provision or
provide a choice of sites to meet the
needs of the gypsy and traveller
community as a consequence the council's
current policy approach conflicts with
national policy
in terms of a possibility of an
application coming forward for gypsy and
travel accommodation
the site has been allocated for nearly
eight years the council has not worked
with the current or previous site owners
to bring forward the allocation the
council does not own the site and would
have to secure it by compulsive purchase
purchases you've heard an extremely
costly and uncertain process
and the owner of the site does not want
to bring forward the gypsy and travel
accommodation this possibility cannot
therefore be judged to represent a
reasonable prospect a point which
underpins your officers conclusions
finally officers believe that the
consented outline scheme will deliver
economic benefits this belief has
reduced the weight afforded to the
economic benefits proposed
this is founded upon the belief that the
consented scheme will come forward if
this application is refused this is
simply not the case
the commercial impact the policy gt1
allocation is such that the consented
development will not proceed the
development committee therefore need to
weigh the potential loss of the
employment benefits when considering the
application this evening
the gypsy and traveler used to the land
will sterilize the adjacent employment
allocation
the opportunity before you this evening
is both significant and compelling
the application the application responds
directly to strong market demand it will
deliver 30 000 square meters of modern
high quality industrial warehouse floor
space presenting a unique opportunity
for the district there is nothing of
this scale in the area and its presence
would present a clear statement that
rochford is open to new business
turning down this application represents
a significant reputational and financial
risk to the council by saying no to jobs
in investment because of a gypsy and
travellers site in the wrong location
that may never come forward i therefore
urge you to support this planning
application this evening thank you
thank you and before we i carry on i
have noted that councillor fd williams
sparring and smith i've got
non-pecuniary interests for being on the
executive
correct anyone else done
thank you
other non-members how do you wish to
speak
on this no
i will then bring it into the
committee um
oh i've got a couple of hands here but
with that councillor fd then oh sorry
it's got sorry it's got to be uh council
royal because he is
and the other's a question uh which i
i'm a little bit vague on um
as i see it
whatever you stand on this we're talking
about travel of community and we have an
obligation to provide a site for this
this community
and um
my understanding is at the time when
this was selected a lot of work went in
by other members to sort out this
particular site and for a very good
reason
and then we have this application come
along and suddenly we seem to be talking
about the travelers as though they were
secondary to this and and i feel quite
strong about that i'm not i'm not a
major supporter but i do think we're
talking about people and we have a legal
obligation as i understand it to provide
a site if we do away with this site
regardless of all the circumstances i've
heard we've got to find another site and
that will be quite
quite traumatic i imagine because
there'll be opposition wherever you go
but
that's my first point on this really but
i have a question in which i could be
put right because i'm not i'm a little
bit vague now i remember some couple of
years ago now we worked with highways
with the uh
refurbishment of the railway and they
were putting in a roads coming off the
a130 coming across to that road their
exit
um by the railway there and they raised
x amount 94 million or something to
progress this all to do with rady weir i
know it's highways but um it was my
understanding where that exit point is
there that's where the road was going
and they were going to go across the
road
and then turn right towards the a127
where a new lane was going to be put in
now some people might remember this but
to my knowledge that was all you
remember that was all agreed and it was
all gonna i know they've taken their
time things are like that but my
understanding that was approved for them
by the highways people it's nothing to
do with us so my question is how does
this interfere with that road
council can i take all the questions oh
yeah yeah
yeah
members can we take all the questions
then ask the officers to answer them if
uh katie's got the questions laid down
i'm laying them out as well okay uh can
you
sorry counselor fdm
chairman um
i'd actually
i find it coming from all the other side
of the district i find it's very
difficult to
place in my mind the scowl
and the context of this site so i'd
actually like to propose a difference to
have a site visit
can we just do the questions
yeah i guess that's fine
and then we'll come back to you for is
that emotion you're putting through yes
this motion
have we i'll second that
okay
right so
mr councilman smith uh thank you
chairman so if we're talking to the um
the motion for deferment i'd just like
to
explain my reasons why i feel i might be
able to support that
um clearly we we have had the importance
of the
traveller site explained to us by other
members and there is a long history to
the generation of that site
um i think now that we're in the
position we're in a deferment would give
members the opportunity to have that
site visit and to see the practical
location of it
i think it will also give officers time
to give consideration to the
um issue around the financial
contribution because just listening
carefully to the speaker that we had
mentioning a value of four hundred
thousand pounds contribution but equally
a few moments later saying it would be
about 1.3 million pounds to develop a
site
1.3 million pounds in that location or
another location it's still 1.3 million
so there's a bit of a a mismatch there
that needs further exploring and then
when we get to the issue of highways
the report is thorough and comprehensive
but when it comes to the highways
authority we've simply got the line that
they support
and some conditions that they suggest i
think with such a
significant location
members
would require
further understanding of how the highway
solution would work
and obviously not directly part of the
application but i think still think
relevant to our consideration
is the proposed development of the fair
glenn interchange given the absolute
proximity and the impact of any changes
there on any proposed
acts further access
to the
uh to the main road from the site
particularly around peak times on such a
busy uh
a busy road i see that the highways
agency are more concerned about
further impact on junctions much further
away
but clearly
with the number of
parking
slots that are on the on the application
the detail of how
the proposed highway
solution would work
and the detail of a signalized junction
and the impact of that i i do believe uh
there is a lot more detail required
there so i would be more than happy
to support a motion for deferment uh
with with possible site visit to further
explore those options thank you
thank you
you've got one
councillor norman can you park as
requested can you pass the
plea
okay thank you
listening to all of the arguments and
all the points put forward it seems as
though the biggest stumbling block is
the obvious one is the allocation of the
gypsies and traveller
uh parking out the the developer has
actually suggested putting money to this
but i don't i don't think that that is
really going to solve the issue because
uh from memory the council had quite a
job trying to find
a site for this allocation
i wonder if we could propose um that the
uh condition be put on this but if no
you can't because we're talking to the
motion
okay all right well once you
all right so if you want me to bring it
back to the next one then i'll bring it
back to the next one but it might
actually then
cause more complications i think i think
actually the
motion to defer
is uh is probably preemptive because the
site is pretty obvious i mean anyone who
goes on that junction is going to see it
i mean
the development there is absolutely huge
and you cannot fail to understand where
it is
if you've got any points you'd like our
officers to explore
uh counselors
let them know and then that will be
sorted out until we come back up let's
have us after the site visit and then we
obviously will do this will come forward
have you any points you need to be
explored for this site visit
sorry
it might be worthwhile just
understanding
about our condition if you it just might
be useful if you were going to make a
point about a possible condition
theoretically i know we're talking to
emotion of deferment but um it might be
useful if we are deferring if that is
the end result that then
we're clear about everything that we
need to to sort of consider
okay
uh what i was going to suggest is
it seems like a
a logical thing from a business point of
view
to put across as a suggestion because
one of the things that the council has
found a real problem with is actually
finding a site for the gypsy and
traveller
accommodation that we need to have as
part of our
government
allocation
and requirements to provide it's all
very well the uh applicant coming
forward and saying he'll give a huge
amount of money but if we can't find a
site then we're still stuffed
so i would
what the thing i'd like to explore
is the possibility of instead of
actually
requiring a financial contribution that
the actual applicant as part of the um
agreement to proceed presuming that goes
ahead that they actually find and
purchase another site equivalent to this
the actual site itself i don't think is
practical to develop not in its present
place thank you stanley then we'll
take a vote
um
with reference to
uh
page 7.13
paragraph
are we talking
to the motion yeah yeah
which
will tell us
that uh
that the site is
really
um one that hasn't there's nothing on it
it's just bear land and i just wonder
that just go into the site
and it's quite visible up there
when we see the where the gypsy and
travelers site needs to be located
is that there is nothing there there is
absolutely nothing there and what i'm
asking is
is that
even if we what are we
aiming to do once we see it
in
reality
yeah i know but what are we going to go
there to see until we see it i mean i've
never no sorry i've never been there so
i would like to see the site and see how
it's proposed as we've been to other
sites where there's been a fair bit of
land
our offices have given us some uh plan
and then we can discuss it and this is
what we're trying to do tonight right
okay so i'll get i get the idea of what
what's been said
but i've got to ask
can i ask for another deferment please
well we're asking for a deep number
we're working on this deferment yep so
we could we've got a motion forward it's
been seconded that we defer it for a
site visit and then once we i've allowed
people to speak on this so our officers
know what points we've got they would
need clarified then we'll take a vote
yes or no for a site visit
and then another development can be made
why do you want to make another
confirmer
please
well
what are you going to do for the
department i would that i would like to
make a deferment to this proposal to
find out exactly
where the council is in this
uh purchase of the land right
because without that we
we're looking at we don't know what
we're looking at
[Music]
it was
if uh it had been stated the land could
uh purchase compulsory purchase not it
is
so that is not a stage we're even
looking at yet we are looking about this
development
to see
what has been proposed by the applicant
to see if it's and
councillor fds said he would would like
to have it have it put a motion forward
to have it deferred so we can all have a
look at the sites
i personally
would like to go and have a look at the
site it might just be a rough piece of
ground but i still
even if i hadn't
regardless of the gypsy and travellers
site i would like to see the site how it
is laid out like we have a cherry
orchard
okay and that is what we're doing
tonight
okay who else do we got to speak because
then i want to close this
council williams please
thank you i shall be brief
um is your microphone
i think so
my question is have the
applicants offered
an alternative site for the gypsy and
traveller
encampment thank you
i'm conscious that i haven't got back to
any questions at all i think they were
saving them for the end but in the midst
there's been a deferment um
that needs to be voted on at some stage
but at some point i suppose i need to
get back to the questions that have been
asked
at the end whenever thank you
councillor
thank you chairman just a quick question
to be discussed at the site visit if
possible um the applicant has been
putting stuff out suggesting that the
site is not suitable nor deliverable i'm
quoting ldc as having some view on that
so i'd like to discuss that when we have
the site visit please
yeah that's no problem
right members can we have a vote
on who
for agreeing to have a site visit please
do the site visit deferment
get it right
against
[Music]
thank you
we're taking item 9
as stated at the beginning of the
meeting
reports here right
um
so i think council lawman the first
question was about um
highway works that was surrounding the
site and i think yes there is um it's
called a fairglen interchange i think is
what's been referred to
and i once i haven't got the precise
details of what is
um involved in that um clearly the
federal and interchange works are very
close to this site in part
and the highways authority when they
made the recommendation um
in terms of the access being appropriate
have taken those works those wider works
into consideration
and i think councillor smith
sort of
asked as well if these additional things
could be maybe explored
perhaps in an addendum that officers can
put together and prior to the next
hearing of this application and then
following the site visit and i think um
councillor smith was asking for the
impacts of the proposed access here and
how they
affect or
the fair glen interchange works to just
give members clarity um about
what those impacts might be
and just reassurance from the hives
authority that they've been properly
considered and they're still happy with
this access that's my understanding but
i don't have that further detail to give
you right now
i think the other question i had
down was
half the applicants offered an
alternative site
that
no
in short
i think
maybe we'll leave it at that
for now i don't think i had any other
questions i think there were other
comments um
and i've noted down a few things that
are maybe for us to look at
on an addendum to give members more
information about certain things before
it's heard again thank you very much
no we can't go back forward now we're
just
we can't we're not discussing it it's
just the questions that were asked from
katie
no you're not
we haven't got a date for we've got as
you know the procedure
we have you do know the procedure we
have a date for the site visit
and then when we've had the site visit
and our offices can get the additional
information
they will then put it on to an agenda
for us to come back to discuss it
and then it will be discussed again
right at members as we stated it right
at the beginning we're going to go on to
item
nine
instead so if you
shuffle your papers around a little bit
i do uh do apologize
so
this is item nine it's the land north of
london road and west aurora industrial
state rural
lane and it will be clear
oh hello hello hello happy evening
thank you claire
good evening and this is a reserve
matters application for the construction
of a care home in association with the
development approved for up to 500
runnings by outline planning commission
at land north of london road and south
of roar of lane rally in 2016.
the reserve matters for consideration
are access appearance landscaping layout
and scale
as you can see from the location plan
the site is a small parcel of land here
separated from the wider
london road site by the roar of land
industrial estate road if i have a plan
to please katie
so this plan shows the site in context
with the wider outline application so we
have the application site allocated for
non-residential uses located here to the
north eastern corner of the wider site
and as you can see we've got the
residential parcels some of which will
be partly being constructed at the
moment and you can see attenuation
ratings and wider immunity space as well
but this is the site that we're talking
about in the wider context of the site
allocation
we'd have plan three please katie
so the proposal is for a 60 bed care
home across three floors we've
associated landscaping to the boundary
edges as you can see all around here
landscaping around these edges
and immediately space to the west this
is where the immunity space would be
located
access into the wharf um
industrial estate road to the south so
you'd come down the wall of lane
industrial state road and then there
will be the access to this point here
and we've got parking as well to this
south eastern corner of the site we have
planned four places
so this is a 3d visual of the building
and proposed when viewed from london
road the building would act as a feature
building to the london road development
using mixture of materials and
elevational treatments
move on to plan five piece kt
so this is another 3d visual just viewed
from the residential development site
looking towards the immunity area so you
said this would be where the immunity
area is located here and this section
here is and sort of backwards is the
wider allocation residential development
site
and finally plan six please katie
and this is a 3d visual from within the
site looking across from the parking
area so this would be the parking area
here this is actually the main entrance
um
inside the site here
during the course of the application
revised plans were provided removing a
substation that was considered to
interfere with the root protection zone
of a protected tree and the overall
height was reduced to record the height
parameters of the outline application
some other design and minor layout
changes were also made
the key material planning considerations
are access design and appearance
landscaping scale layout drainage
planning conditions and rams
if we can go back to plan three piece
katie
thank you
so with regards to the access you do
zoom in a little bit more if possible
thank you
the supporting information indicates
that the main vehicle and pedestrian
access to the site is direct from the
road which serves wars industrial estate
this
access would include a linkage with the
existing pedestrian footwear on the
eastern side of the wall of industrial
state road so as you can see here um
this is the existing pedestrian footwear
here so the site so someone could come
down this footpath here and access the
site in here
pedestrian wise
the access provides visibility of 2.4
meters by 43 meters which is the
recommended distance for a 30 mile per
hour zone and that is shown by the
orange type hatching that you can see
here
a sweatpath analysis has been undertaken
which confirms that a refuse vehicle can
access a maneuver within the site and
again you can see the swept path
analysis here so an example vehicle
maneuvering within the site and still
coming out in forward gear
county heart rate is not object to the
proposal subject to conditions and the
proposed access arrangements are
considered acceptable
looking at design and appearance move to
plan four please katie
so the overall visual impression of the
building is that on the basis of its
t-shaped layout it offers visual
interest in all elevations being
multi-aspect in its outlook it is
considered that the stepping of the
building line on prominent elevations
help break up the massing and the
character features such as bays and
gables to the main elevations soften the
overall massing of the building and
provide visual interest and contrast
material usage includes red multi-stock
brick with cladding finished in two
colours of dark gray and white pearl and
smooth grey
slate or tiles to the roof it's
considered that the proposed development
would form an attractive feature
building functional for its purpose and
use
looking at landscaping if we have a look
at plan 3 again please katie
due to the relatively level topography
of the site no banks territories or
earthquakes are proposed as part of this
development the site has previously been
cleared of vegetation and trees and the
existing band of trees and vegetation
situation adjacent to the existing
footpath are of high immunity and
ecological value which will be retained
and integrated into the site landscaping
scheme so that's that section you can
see here that currently exists
and will be maintained as part of this
proposal
a variety of hard and soft landscaping i
suppose as shown all of which is
considered acceptable we'll go to plan
five please katie
so the maximum ridge height proposes
12.5 metres
officers are satisfied that by reason of
its scale particularly its height that
the development is within the defined
parameters of scale set outline planning
stage and aligns with the height of the
development set adjacent to the west
the footprint of the building with its
t-shaped design is considered acceptable
as a feature building such as this
given the separation distances it is not
considered that the scale of the
development would cause harm to the
visuality of the area nor the amenity of
any property in the burnham way the
building is not considered to be out of
character in terms of height and mass
with other houses and developments along
rural flame
we moved back to uh plan three again
please katie
so looking at layouts the layout has
been carefully considered so that the
public access to the east of the site
links around to the footpath which
provides a safe access onto royal
industrial estate there will be a safe
and secure southwest facing garden
activity area already identified here
and dining and lounge areas are served
by patio and terraces leading out onto
an overlooking communal garden space
there is a refuse store which is
considered provide sufficient space for
the storage of refuse at the site so
that refuse store is located here
it is not considered the development by
a reason of its layout and given its
degree of separation from neighbouring
properties would result in direct
overlooking or overshadowing of
neighbouring properties to the east in
luverne and way
the parking layout shows the provision
of 24 car parking spaces accessed via a
central area which would also be used by
service vehicles
revisions were made during the course of
the application to ensure that the
parking spaces meet the preferred bay
sizing and to increase the number of
spaces to the 24 figure
the quantum of parking proposed is
considered acceptable
a cycle and power two wheeler store is
provided south of the building so that's
in this location just here
which would provide adequate
accommodation for these modes of
transport overall the proposed layout is
considered acceptable
looking at drainage details have been
provided provided as part of this
application to address an initial
holding objection from the lead local
flood authority however the outline
application has conditions requiring
surface water drainage details to be
agreed and this would still need to be
addressed separate to any details
provided as part of the current
application
renewable energy so conditions on the
outline application sufficiently control
this and looking at conditions in
general various conditions relating to
higher matters the hedgerow to the
eastern edge requirement for a walk over
by an ecologist and compliance with the
construction management plan are
suggested to name but a few
and then finally looking at rams as the
proposed development is a c2 use which
is distinctly different from a c3 use it
is not considered to fall within the
scope of the essex coast recreational
disturbance avoidance and mitigation
strategy
zone of influence as relevant
development and no mitigation is
considered necessary
this application is recommended for
approval subject to conditions as
detailed within the officer report
thank you
no
members any other members
no
isn't it sorry have you um would you
like to say something
would you like to take the microphone
um first of all um
there is a public right-of-way uh path
way
across the site from roy of lane to the
industrial estate
um is that going to be kept
or
and what uh
what manner is the
upgrading it on with the with the site
by the developer
um
the the obviously my main concern
is because that is seeks that's actually
a
bowl
effect uh land
and uh it does
that's where most of the water goes from
rory flame when it when it does rain
and i'm concerned i know there is a
separate plan
for the uh surface water and and what
have you but i think we need to be
uh vigilant
on that
um
very much so uh
that's the reason why we've asked
countryside to put in more ponds
than is necessary because of that area
that does
actually have a lot of water retainment
i'm fully in agreement with using this
parcel of land
for such a development i think it's a
a good a good idea although
i'm
somewhat a little bit concerned on the
height of the buildings as
relatively to
other buildings
close by in relation to the
park
the burnham way development
could the
officer give me a height
in relation to that
path development please
thank
you okay
um in relation to the public right away
so yes that that won't be impacted by
the development um
that will be retained and we do also
have a condition which was suggested as
well condition 16 which requires it to
be um upgraded um now that will be in a
manner which will then be between the
applicant and county highways to
determine in terms of how that actually
works because it will be then that
obviously will then be in control of the
public right away um surface water
drainage um to confirm the lead low
profile authority have come back and
said that they've moved their holding
objection to the application anyway as
part of this but it's the outline
applications really deal with the
the more finite detail of the drainage
and condition that detail on the whole
wider side which in companies
encompasses this as well um so they
still will be addressed as part of the
wider outline application um separate to
this
um and it's all controlled by that with
regard to the heights of the buildings
and i do know that the flats that have
been constructed on the wider side were
12.3 meters so we're looking at 12.5
here with the care home development i
don't actually i can't actually tell you
a height of any of the neighbors in la
burnham way that's not something i
actually have the information i'm afraid
i'm in terms of comparison but they are
considered to be a reasonable distance
away in order that i don't think you'd
see um
quite an extensive massing difference
between the two because of the sort of
separation distance between where the
pros care home is and the burning way
houses and would be always an officer
perspective on it and was concluded
really in the report um but the actual i
can't give you your heart on the block
the berlin property isn't afraid
can i come back on that please
which is um quite under developed
obviously the top floor so
in relation to
this building as being three floors that
is
what's happened to the house is actually
three floors
so if you understand what i mean um
because they've developed the loft but
nevertheless
it's still
a house with a
loft if you get and i'm looking at the
height being a little
somewhat half a meter maybe higher than
that development is there any any way we
can get that reduced a little bit
so
fall in line with the line through the
i when we've already as part of this
current application and when it was
originally submitted it was already a
greater height than we're currently
looking at
um
in terms of scale and impact officers
perspective because this is designed to
be a feature building within the site
of the london road development
we are as officers happy with the size
and scaling that we are currently seeing
in terms of the proposal on the site and
that's the
perspective on it in terms of the height
and massive
thank you thank you chairman
councillor smith
thank you
um
i've spent some time with former
councillor hudson
over the years
and
i i distinctly remember him talking
about
ditches verges and gullies
on that site running from that site and
going across the road and this looks
like an opportunity to resolve some of
that long-term
infrastructure but i'm a little bit
disappointed that we're potentially
looking at houses there there's a site
that strikes me as absolutely prime for
retail but we've got the application
that's in front of us so that's what
we've got to deal with um
from what i've seen in the in in the
outline i'm i'm not enamored with the
quality of the design because um rorith
lane is a
a prominent entry
into the town
and i don't think that the style and
quality of the design there quite
justifies
um
quite justifies that obviously it's not
the threshold entrance to the town now
the walls depart development has has
taken that but still it's a significant
location and i'm a little bit
disappointed there but the one thing
within what we have before us
is
if we could possibly just show the
boundary treatment
um on on the roar of industrial estate
road
it just strikes me that given the the
um a the
view if possible please
um
that
that and a little bit further around it
strikes me given the nature of the vip
the majority of vehicles that will be
using the industrial estate while it's
still an industrial state the height of
that boundary given the the height and
the bulk of the vehicles just doesn't
really do it justice you can see i think
i think maybe fencing to
possibly one more day but i think a a
solid boundary as high as you could
reasonably get away with
would be a good amendment to the
conditions that we've got in front of us
but essentially in planning terms
um
there aren't too many objections that we
can make to it but i would like to
seek advice and possibly further member
support on some further treatment to
that uh that boundary bordering roar of
industrial
road thank you
thank you chairman um
again i'm going to talk about parking
page uh nine point two three
if you look at
uh three point seven eight and correct
me if i'm wrong clear
24 spaces i proposed or was it 28
now
at any day any day there's going to be
they say 32 staff take time shift
so where the
the other's going to park where visitors
going to park
the nearest
um bus is along
is aging goes to chanceford city centre
so what about local people want to work
there
the
other bus stops nearest one is 1.6
kilometers away
walking distance a 20-minute walk and
there's another one which is
two which
800 kilometer 800 meters away which is
not
really good enough okay in the summer
where you can see what you're doing if
you're on a day shift finishing six
seven o'clock in the dark
it's not that's not good it's got
cycling provision there but no cycle
route or marked out spaces anywhere near
it
it seems to come down to parking again
it's i know you say it's acceptable but
i don't really think it's acceptable
thank you
yes um i'll come back on council smith
as well one on
one um so the boundary treatment we did
actually start with um
fencing along that edge and
as officers we encourage them to provide
a more sort of attractive i suppose
edging along there um but it's certainly
something that if we're not happy with
what we're currently seeing so in terms
of the 3d visual we can adapt the um
condition to reflect that we want
something different along that edge and
to be agreed by us as officers we have
got a landscaping condition anyway and
so we can
adapt that to incorporate that as well
um i definitely think it's important to
get something that's attractive and
works on that edge being a corner plot
location and
at the moment i think what we're seeing
i wouldn't say as officers we would
necessarily object to because we got to
a point where we discussed with them um
that an alternative and this is what
they came back with so we concluded that
we were happy with it but if if members
feel that they want something uh
differing to that then we can
adapt a condition to consider that
so it's an existing there should be an
existing condition on landscaping anyway
um
yeah so condition eight we've got on
soft landscaping so it's just that um
soft land could be approved landscape
plan should be undertaken within the
first planting season so we could just
um adapt that to include within there
and and
uh boundary treatment to the edging
fronting law of lane and into the
industrial estate to be submitted to in
a grade something along those lines
within if members felt
that necessary
and on the matter of car parking and as
you'll see within the report we went
into quite a bit of depth in terms of
assessing the car parking um
and its adequacy on the sites 24 spaces
they're proposing and our parking
standards um refer to a maximum figure
so i suppose from a from an officer
point of view it then does make it quite
difficult for us to sort of really argue
um
an entire quantum really because we've
got a maximum figure that we're working
to rather than the minimum and they
provided evidence the applicant of other
care homes that they have seen
throughout the country that have
provided this kind of accommodation they
consider it appropriate and county
highways don't object to the quantum
proposed um
whilst we've got a condition with
regards to upgrading existing bus stops
proposed not locating anything new but
upgrading existing um it's considered
from an officer perspective that we
don't feel we can go any further in
terms of the parking division than we
didn't think it'd be a justified reason
for refusal here that's offers a
perspective on the parking
want to come back
please if you might yeah if you can
is it the highways responsibility
for
the
uh
bus
bus stops and and
as such or is this part of it is it part
of the developers
development if you like to make to to
make these bus stops available
so bus stops are in the control of
county highways and it's just a matter
of whether we sometimes we will impose
conditions as advised and guided by
county highways as part of applications
where necessary to mitigate harm by a
development so in this case county
highways have suggested some
improvements to existing bus stops
within the area and we've considered
that as officers and consider it is
appropriate and reasonable to impose and
require that part of this application
thank you
the recommendation is is proposed that
the committee resolves that the reserve
matters be approved subject to the
following conditions and i'm not going
to read them all out this is far too
many have i have second of course
and also
that includes the amendment
uh
can i have a vote on them for acceptance
please
any
against
so that's 12 4 1 again that is carried
that's approved thank you members
chairman may i always have an
embarrassment request for short concept
of course you can then i can have a
quick walk with this crutch to get my
hip going thank you very much we have
five minutes
this is the gender item
of london
and western industrial estate and it'll
be mike's tracks which will present the
officers report thank you chairman um
this application is to the countryside
site but a different part of it if we
could jump straight to the next plan
please claire
um and if it's possible to zoom out i'd
be grateful that's great thank you
we're just looking at a simple issue
tonight chairman which is the strategic
landscaping the the outlying permission
that's been granted
um
includes amongst other things the
presentation to the council of the sort
of strategy to landscape the site the
actual
components of the landscaping like the
species density and things like this are
actually reserved as conditions normally
cleared by offices so you've got a
straightforward i would like to think
application here
which you've seen something like this
before for another part of the site and
we're now dealing with the southeast
corner this is the
edge of the roarth industrial state and
some housing down here which i think is
off victoria avenue
this is this strip of land buffering the
industrial state and then in the corner
here the communal areas of allotments
and what have you and it goes on off the
screen up to the access point so just to
run through
they are proposing in amongst that
formal two meter wide pathways inbound
shingle service
with a moan pathways as alternatives the
use of meadow grassland for species
diversity on other planets
for habitat and to complement the
watercourse and vegetation that runs
through
part of the site
the use of tussocky and wetland
grassland areas i think you've seen
before that some parts of the
development they've got low ways as well
as digging ponds they have depressions
in the soil to
take surface rain water and then there's
certain grasses that favor that that
relief
the use of native scrub particularly in
this bottom corner
there's a reason for that because it's
next to the communal areas of the
allotments the play area
a kickabout area
and other provision youth facilities so
there's communal orchard as well in the
here is the
scrub there is a communal orchard
amongst that so there's a feature around
the communal uses of the site
as well as a belt of woodland trees and
mounding there another feature of this
where if those with a sharp eye can just
see a pink straight line there that is a
acoustic barrier fence
and that's put in together with the use
of trees and mounding uh to the to the
two features complement each other the
fence and the landscaping to to mitigate
noise um there's also ecological areas
there's one area on the side and further
to the south there's no need to go there
on the screen
but there's a pond on the south side
that's outside of the site but it's
combining the landscaping in here to
enhance the
landscape corridor and therefore enhance
the species diversity
the proposed the pros will um would
include 1.8 metre high green mesh
fencing world mesh fencing around the
allotments
and
the recommendation chairman
is approval subject to the condition set
out in the report
thank you very much
there are nice uh
members of the public speaking on this
item
are does any of our
non-members attending want to speak
is that that's a no
our wall councillors are
councillor stanley that's it i think
you're the only one aren't you
stanley please
thanks
thank you chairman um
the
question that i've got to ask is that
how do we how does the allotments
get
how do we get onto the allotment site
from
the roaring industrial estate i
i thought that there was a
opening
on the
from the royal industrial estate at the
moment there is an opening which which
they
i seem to see
that they're using
um is that
is that not practical any longer in the
corner
and also
who is
who is going to
mow this this meadow grass and and keep
the area
tidy
because
it looks like there isn't a
access point
anywhere down there for
for equipment to do such
i just wondered if there was
could we
ask for an access point
somewhere along that side
at all
thank you chairman um actually the
what we're dealing with is like one
piece of a jigsaw yeah so
uh i'm at some disadvantage that
i think
we've not sought an access from north
industrial state but in amongst here is
a footpath
okay so there are pedestrian links but
you'll see there's a vehicular access
out this part here
and you mentioned about the maintenance
of the site it will be done by a
management company
and their compound
is there
is that there
yes that's that's the management
companies
sorry i've struggled to make it um
the the so so actually this this like
communal area which i was alluding to i
thought there's a number of features
around as well as the allotment um this
is the corner where the the management
company would be based or at least have
their equipment
and my understanding is the whole site
the residential development these
aspects the other landscaping areas etc
they are all be administered by a
management company
so they will have access throughout the
site to the open areas they will be
based in this corner and the access is
parking and cycle provision for the
allotments also here so the access
presumably comes out here somewhere into
other parts of the development that have
that have been agreed but i haven't got
a plan that jigsaws all those together
to show you so i perhaps ask if members
can trust me that the access the
vehicles come through here but there's
other permeability through footpath
linkages through the site that's if
you're happy to carry
your tools and things over your shoulder
as it were but there is vehicular access
you can be a result of it stanley on
page 8.7 3.33 it does give you the whole
information about the car parking spaces
cut cycle spaces and it also last
sentences the management company storage
areas is also accommodated in this area
so it is in your in your package if you
you know again try to visualize it
perhaps we can't visualize a piece of
ground that we can't see
but if you want a site visit we can go
and have a site visit to see it if
you're asking for that no no no no i'm
just asking if you can't visualize it
you would like clarity we you can have
we will defer this and have a site visit
is that what you're asking no right
thank you
just want to make sure you're we're
clear on that i'm clear on that thank
you councillor
thank you just a very quick one on uh my
experience that i've had with hockley
allotments i don't see any provision or
for water
on the allotments that was a very very
protracted issue at hockley and we could
perhaps
circumvent that by making that a
condition of this approval
thank you chair
could our members are in agreement to
ask the officers for a condition to put
make water on the site can we have a
vote please
just to make sure we're all clear
our arthur council williams
chairman may i
interrupt again um is the council in
contact with the uh
parish that uh is
taking oh
being uh asked for that isn't the
planning issue that's going to be taken
outside yes i'm just wondering if the
officers have asked yeah well perhaps we
could ask that our out office meeting
because this is that is not a planning
um
issue what we're discussing tonight
thank you sorry
can't squeeze did you finish with what
you were saying thank you sorry i just
wanted to yes thank you anyone else
sorry jack sorry mr uh norman sorry
sorry i don't apologize no i think
you've already answered it all i was
going to say is who's paying for the
management who's covering all that cost
that doesn't matter that's so we're just
going to build something and then
with a management
company referred to
other papers it is the residence etc
yeah right
there is a recommendation
there is a recommendation
uh
it is proposed that committee resolves
that
that reserve matters be approved subject
to the following conditions and again
i'm not going to read them out
can i have it
oh and obviously plus the uh condition
with the water as per cancer
uh aids and agreed by all members
so could i have a vote
oh sorry can we have a second
uh cancer swearing
can we have a vote on for acceptance
please
that is that is unanimous thank you
members
the last item
on the agenda is item 10
vote one this has been referred from the
weekly list
and it's the demolition of seven
hillside avenue
there are no
um
presentations uh no presentations from
their council that called in
is there any outside
[Laughter]
um so this application is for the
demolition of an existing dwelling and
the construction of two detached
four-bedroom houses with associated
external works and amenity as you can
see from the location plan the site is
located to the eastern side of hillside
avenue here
within the residential area of hawkworld
the site borders other dwellings um to
the north and south within hillside
avenue and to the east within bosworth
first he sits around the bloodwings here
and we move to plan two please katie
so this is just a photo of the existing
dwelling which is a detached bungalow on
a reasonable size plot at the moment and
move to planet three please katie thank
you
the proposal is tomorrow's existing
dwelling construct two detached
two-story dwellings as shown here so you
can see the two that proposed in this
location here
new vehicular crossovers would be
created onto hillside avenue to serve
the dwellings each drilling would have
an external depth of approximately 15
meters at the deepest point and width of
approximately seven meters
approximate heights would be five meters
to the eaves eight meters to the main
ridge and seven meters to the ridge of
the front wing materials will be red
face brick work at ground floor with
upper walls in white painted render with
grey plane roof tiles
the key material planning considerations
are impact on character impact on
residential amenity garden sizes impact
on highway safety sustainability issues
trees and ecology
so impact on character the proposed
positioning of the dwellings is not
objected to in principle however the
plot width distances would be less than
9.25 meters per detached dwelling and
the dwellings would also not achieve a
two meter separation between the two
proposed weddings as required within the
council supplemental planning document
two so those distances are what refer to
here so the distance across the actual
plot which here are considered to be
under our requirements along with the
separation distance between the two
buildings here
the proposed layout and setting would
not have a good relationship with the
surrounding area with the lack of
separation between the proposed
dwellings and the lack of plot width
resulting in tightly packed development
at odds with the more spacious character
of the locality
the proposal was considered to be
contrary to policy cpu run of the core
strategy and policies dm1 and dm3 the
development management plan and the mppf
and this represents an opposite reason
for refusal here
looking at impact on residential amenity
the site borders other domains to the
north and south and hillside avenue and
to the east within bosworth close
the 45 degree test to ensure no
unacceptable overshadowing occurs has
been here too
the development would not be considered
to give rise to overlooking or
overshadowing with naving properties
looking at garden sizes both of the
properties will be provided with rear
priority means to spaces of 185 meters
squared and 188 meters squared in excess
of the required hundred meters squared
which would satisfy the outdoor
amenities space requirements as set out
in supplementary planning document two
impact on highway safety so the site
provides a necessary two resident
parking bays per dwelling to the
appropriate sizes within the parking
standard document and the two new
vehicular accesses are considered
acceptable
no visitor parking is proposed but on
small developments such as this it is
normally acceptable if adderall equipped
parking is otherwise provided per unit
which is the case here
only one space overall would technically
be required this is not considered to
represent a justified officer reason for
refusal here there were no obvious
on-street parking issues that would
result as a witness during office visit
to the site
looking at sustainability issues all new
dwellings are required to comply with a
new national space standard as set out
in the technical housing standards
nationally described space standard of
march 2015
the proposed dwellings would exceed the
requirements
a planning condition would be
recommended if planning permission were
to be approved to ensure compliance with
the necessary water efficiency standard
looking at trees so there's a tree and
there are trees and shrubs situated to
the eastern and southern boundaries of
the site
some of the trees and shrubs would have
either been removed or pruned the trees
are not protected and whilst they offer
some visual amenity within the site they
are not considered to be of any
significance and therefore the works to
the trees are considered acceptable
and then finally ecology the proposal is
within the scope of the essex coast
recreational disturbance avoidance and
mitigation strategy rams as it falls
within the zone of influence for likely
impacts and is a relevant residential
development type
it is considered that mitigation would
in the form of a financial contribution
be necessary in this case the required
financial contribution of 127 pound 30
per dwelling has not been paid to the
local planning authority it therefore
remains unclear as to whether the
necessary mitigation would be provided
for here and this represents a second
officer reason for refusal
this application is recommended for
refusal for the two reasons outlined in
the report
council smith
thank you chairman um
the reasons for refusal have been quite
clearly explained to us by officers um i
know i did note uh councillor mason in
her reason for uh referring mentioned
carl parking but officers have visited
the site and there weren't any
particular issues so that would not be
sustainable so i am quite happy with
what's presented in front of us and i'm
quite happy to move the reason for
refusal
have i got a second of that counselor
sure mr shaw
so i
i second that we uh
the proposal that we refuse
because i think it will affect what
you're proposing
we've got emotion at the moment yeah you
want that
the reason being why um there was no
parking issue actually uh
seen while you were there is number one
the actual property itself is empty and
the two bungalows that are opposite are
also empty due to bereavements so it's
given you a misleading position i live
at the top of the road there and i can
assure you there is a parking problem
down there and once these are developed
and those two bungalows get actually
taken up that will become a parking
problem
guaranteed so i mean
i i'm actually
minded to
say that we actually include parking as
an issue
for refusal
just to sort of come back obviously it's
totally accepted that a visit to the
site is a snapshot in time anyway um
of circumstances and things can can
change and and there is impact um i mean
i just yes
can we have oh sorry
on the motion for refusal
and a second up
what council can you re do your
amendment councillors please
that the um
uh
parking standard
um should remain as stated in our policy
and we should have enough room there for
the third car on each site
thank you now can i have a vote
a second do we have a second let's
cancel stanley
can i can i come back and just show a
photo i took inside just to sort of give
a bit of a context of this parking
before we come back on that is that
allowed
also said about the situation
is it allowed
necessary now
um
i think it just shows that perhaps even
with the circumstances that councilor
reeves has described so with the three
weddings uh perhaps not occupied even
taking that into consideration there
still wasn't a lot of parking from the
other
properties within
we're just talking about this one and
we've actually got it as refusal we're
not actually
discussing this
we're discussing an additional reason
for refusal aren't we so i just want to
make sure that we're clear as to whether
that's
definitely a justified third reason for
refusal that's the only reason i sort of
wanted to perhaps just reflect on that
photo
if you go to the
that's the thumbnail
the actual
so the actual site itself is the
bungalow sort of all the way down there
and
so
as cancer has explained this one's not
inhabited um but would have even with
the dwellings there would have two
parking spaces per site um on plot
um and then obviously we've got the
other bungalows that councilors
mentioned are not occupied but
there wasn't on-street parking from
these other surrounding dwellings
irrespective of that situation
we we're talking about one additional
space that we'd be requiring as part of
the parking standards document um and
the impact of that with regards to on
street parking and i mean officer's view
is that it wouldn't be particularly
justified
reason for refusal um for us to try and
defend on a hill and if we ended up sort
of heading that way that's officer
perspective the one of the things that
isn't mentioned in the report is it's
near to the town center i don't believe
that that is a valid reason for actually
okaying the parking because you've got a
gradient going up over the hill to get
there so walking up there the vast
majority of people will not walk and
to say that there's a nearby car parking
uh etcetera it's a fallacy there isn't
right members
sorry
so on the
we're talking about only one additional
space it's just the visitor bay and with
a lot of minor developments like this it
isn't
it isn't unreasonable that we normally
require that kind of amount necessarily
in this country
counselor foster are you going to talk
about the reviews um yes please thank
you chairman um i'm actually against the
refusal
proposal if i may speak
i read the report appendix 1 page
10.1.5.13
describes hillside road as an eclectic
mix of architectural styles and there
are no requirements in this location to
follow distinctly on design
however 0.16 seems to contradict this it
says the proposed element would be
detrimental to the character and
appearance of the site and the
surrounding area
it also says the scale bulk and layout
of the dwellings proposed would not
successfully
reference the prevailing character of
the area appearing out of keeping to the
detriment of the surrounding
street scene so there's a contradiction
actually the immediate nearby street
saying could we put up this street plan
please if you don't mind
right that's it thank you
um
the immediate street scene is not
particularly attractive if viewed from
that site directly opposite which i
think is house number six
is the side of a bungalow with a hedge
up to the roof level
and the
all that's visible there is a roof
covered in solar panels and a very not
well maintained
chimney
the
bungalow below the site
has got a tree line inside its own
boundary which runs completely along the
site completely overgrown hanging over
the site
there is a good view from
looking across the bend some nice
detached houses but as it says at the
start it's it's an eclectic mix of
designs
and i'll go into why that's relevant in
a moment
so as you read through the report it
seems to be leading towards recommending
approval
then it comes to the rams policy
essex recreational disturbance avoidance
and mitigation this means that
development might have adverse effect on
designated coastal sites due to
additional recreational pressure
the mitigation strategy requires a
payment of 127 pound 30 per dwelling
254 pounds 60 in total so it's hardly
additional
recreational disturbance now come to
that to conclude
the report recommends refusal for two
reasons
the first is the proposed development
would create building plots and
dwellings which would not successfully
reference the prevailing character of
the area
and would fail to achieve a positive
relationship with nearby properties
as i said before this would seem to
contradict the earlier statement and i
quote again hillside road is an eclectic
mix of architectural styles there are no
requirements in this location to follow
distinctly on design therefore i would
suggest this is not a valid reason for
refusal
second reason for refusal is that the
application does not include a mechanism
to secure suitable mitigation of 254
pounds 60 towards rams
if this
were
not rejected i would suggest it be
approved with the condition of
the developer making that payment
thank you thank you very much right
members we had a motion um to refuse it
can i have um a show of hands for
them all right we've got to do the
amendment first
right so we've got to vote now for the
amendment if everyone is in an
approval of the amendment please can i
have a show of hands
if you can or otherwise i'm going to
have to extend this meeting i really
don't want to claire because i mean
we're going to have to right because
because otherwise we're going to have to
vote for an
extension of this meeting
oh
please
is
thank you very much
right so can we have a
vote
on the amendment please
before
that's what's been read out that's what
we asked to be read out
so again can i have a show of hands for
agreement
the amendment please
or against
members can we now vote on
the
for refusal plus the one we've just done
for
members voting for the refusal
against
that's carried and it's seeing
4-2 against thank you members
thank you
this conclusive business
9 45.
thank you to 10.